hey everyone this is feed a master
Castillo kabuki here for chess calm and
today I just wanted to share with you
guys a really neat combination that I
found just sort of randomly while
studying some chess and I thought it'd
be a good opportunity to show you guys
some of the beautiful geometric
possibilities in chess so if you want to
just try to solve this puzzle without
any hints feel free to pause your video
right now it's white to play and win
okay so assuming all you ambitious
players already pause your videos and
try to solve the problem and found the
best move already so we're gonna move on
and go ahead and proceed with a solution
and hopefully I can give you guys some
advice as to how to find these sorts of
tactics based on thinking about the
position and the coordination and
harmony of all the pieces sort of
logically by the way plain white here
was the great Viktor Korchnoi and his
opponent was another strong player by
the name of so lock so in this position
if you're trying to solve for the right
combination or the winning sequence of
moves the first thing you always want to
do is look for candidate moves so Canada
moves what that means to me is like the
moves you sort of have to check first
before looking at anything else and
these are typically forcing moves
captures and checks especially checks
right because these are forcing moves
that means that your opponent will often
have only one or two or maybe three
possible replies then it makes things
fall a very clear path and it's very
easy to calculate long variations
because they're there's not a lot of
deviations in your calculation process
also checks and
captures pose danger to your opponent so
you know if you can make your opponent's
king in two moves right that's going to
be much more useful than for example
gaining space on the Queen side right or
if you can capture some kind of pawn or
a piece and then they can't recapture
then obviously that's great and you know
you're going to win the game so that's
why it's always necessary to look for
Canada moves first okay
so what are the candidate moves in this
position
there's ninety five check there's Knight
takes e5 rook takes d6 and Queen takes
e5 basically I listed the only check and
then the three captures right so so
different players have a different
opinion of which moves did you look at
first should you look at the most
promising moves because they're most
likely to work and then you've saved a
lot of time calculating you already
found the best continuation or should
you look at moves that seem very silly
so you can just rule them out
immediately and then forget about them
forever
well again everyone has their own
opinion sometimes I don't know I like to
mix I if one move seems really promising
to me then I'll just look at it first
and calculate as far as I can and then
if it's winning then maybe I'll examine
some other options but most likely I'll
just play that move right other times I
just want to eliminate really silly
moves so I don't waste any time in the
future thinking about them in this case
it's like this move Queen takes e5 right
it's very unlikely that this move leads
to anything white probably just loses a
queen
there's really nothing to look at there
right so we can just eliminate that move
immediately okay so the next move I want
to look at here is ninety five check
right this move seems promising because
it gives a check to the opponent's king
and when you give a check black only has
a number of replies and posing danger to
the opponent's king is usually a good
idea so we should definitely make sure
and check this move so probably blacks
most natural reply to this is Knight
takes d5 and
and now we have to look for more Canada
moves right so we have to look for more
checks or maybe a different capture so
one check that is now available that
wasn't available before is Queen g5
check right since the knight on f6 is
now in d5 but it doesn't take too long
to see that black and simply play his
knight back to f6 and his King is safe
and white hasn't accomplished much
except lose his knight on c3 so 95 check
doesn't seem like a good move because
black can simply take this Knight maybe
it is a good move but it's certainly not
the winning move like if we have to just
recapture the knight on d5 then black
and make some other move and they can
probably defend their position so the
next move I will look at here is rook
takes d6 and the reason I look at this
move next is because if we capture this
pawn and black recaptures with the King
then their King immediately becomes a
little bit more exposed it's now on this
opened e-file right so let's play this
out and now the King is on this opened
e-file suddenly White has a lot more
options which is what makes this move
seem very promising is that suddenly
White has you know rook d1 Czech Queen
d2 Czech Queen d3 Czech and also this
move Knight takes e5 all which seem to
pose a little bit more danger to blacks
King which leads me to believe that
we're on the right track right so now
the next move of this combination is
probably the hardest to find you know
Rick takes d6 it's kind of an obvious
move because it's a candidate move it's
a capture brings the King out in the
open it's very natural to take a look at
this move so now in order to find this
next move you need to be able to be very
aware of what is going on in the
position there are certain tactical
elements that give chess players a hint
that you know they might have some
tactic or combination available to them
in this case not only is the King very
exposed on d6 but the Queen on a5 is
also loose it's not defended
so given that hint I hope everyone by
now has found the next move already
which is Queen d2 check okay so why
Queen d2 check and now Queen d3 check
what's the difference well here the
queen is setting up a discovered attack
against the black queen and as we're
going to see in evaluating blacks
options here is that if this black King
goes to some kind of hot spot for
example e 7 or C 7 then white knight on
c3 can jump with a check and white will
win the Queen on a5 ok so I feel like
now we've discovered sort of the essence
of this combination it's this loose
Queen on a5 so why it gives up his d1
rook for the d6 pawn to not only to
bring blacks King closer to the center
and on an open file but to get his Queen
to d2 with a tempo and you know you
might be wondering well how is it
possible to find this move I mean the
only way to really justify rook takes c6
is by following it up with Queen d2
check none of the other moves lead to
anything well I think the way course no
I found this combination is by first
examining this other move Queen d2 so
Queen d2 comes with the threat of Queen
takes d6 check right and it also comes
with a threat of 95 check winning the
Queen so probably a first use very
excited about this move and you know
even if he was ready to play it at some
point he must have notice that black and
defend against both of these threats
with one move either Queen b6 or Queen
c7 the Queen gets out from the line of
attack on a5 and defends of d6 pawn but
this is when the chess players mind
really starts working is that they they
sort of intuitively realize you know
something clicks in their brain that oh
well if I can get my Queen to d2 with a
tempo black won't have time to get us
Queen out of danger and then maybe I can
set up this discovered attack and when
the
and that's where Rick takes d6 comes
into play right forces the King to d6 of
vulnerable square-y gets his Queen to d2
of the tempo and now as you'll soon
realize Black has no way of escaping
this chat without losing their queen
so King c7 and King II 7 would be met
with 95 check how about King g6
well now look for Canada moves Knight g5
check and the king is forced to go to e7
which is one of those hotspot squares 95
check wins the Queen right okay how
about King c6 look for Canada moves okay
Knight takes e5 check then i of king b6
what's your why play that's right
Queen d6 mate so is that it the answer
is no that's not it right we've
calculated the blacks most simple reply
which is just recapturing the rook right
and we've seen that white wins and all
those lines but rook takes d6 is not a
check you know black actually has
something like I don't know 15 legal
moves here but the point is that we have
to examine black's other options because
black also has forcing moves of their
own fortunately for us there aren't that
many good moves here for black in fact
there's not white is winning
what black plan in the game was probably
the most testing move which is 94 and
this is definitely a move that you
should have looked at if you are trying
to justify this combination tactically
if you're trying to make it work right
black attacks the Queen and now Queen d2
is perfectly acceptable we've defended
the rook blacks King is exposed and we
set up this threat against the Queen on
a5 but why not look for more forcing
moves and in the game course we played
the best move Queen g5 check so now if
Bishop f6
white can play rook takes f6 look for
forcing moves always Knight takes f6 and
Knight d5 check and why does one two
pieces for the rook and it's probably
going to mate in a couple of moves so
that's good for white if Knight f6 I
think simply Queen takes e5 check is
going to lead to either winning a bunch
of material or checkmate or a
combination of the two right so we have
to look at probably Black's best try
here King takes d6
so now what well Queen d2 check but of
course it's a little different here
since blacks 9 + f6 is now in g4 and
this means pretty much two main
differences the first one is that if
black now plays king c6 we don't have
Knight takes e5 check but what can white
do there does white have a way to win if
not then the whole combination doesn't
work for exactly this reason
but fortunately white is still winning
because of Queen d5 check okay follow
along now if King b6 we have Queen d6
check with mate and of King c7 then what
well
Knight b5 check again King b6 Queen d6
mate so King b8 and Queen d6 check
blacks only move is Queen c7 and then
Queen takes c7 mate right that's a
separate line from what we seen so far
but I think it only adds the beauty of
the combination since it's really cool
that why it also had this made available
once the knight left
f6 and went to g4 but of course it was
necessary for course to see that entire
line before playing Rick takes d6 okay
otherwise that move was sort of reckless
if he didn't know for sure that he was
winning in all possible lines
so king g6 now Knight g5 check King f6
and 95 mate right
beautiful checkmate two nights the king
center of the board awesome stuff right
so it didn't make much of a difference
but it was important to realize that
black does have this possibility of
playing is kinked f6 once the knight
comes to g4 so I hope that example was
really entertaining to you guys because
it just shows some of the beautiful
possibilities that chess has to offer
right what gives up his rook and then
obliterates the black king with his
queen and two nights which I don't know
to me is just really nice and then of
course the final position was just
spectacular thanks a lot for listening
and I'll see you around on chess calm